صباح الخير لك مره اخرى قبل دقيقه من الان
مره وفد حكومي على ما يبدو بحسب بعض
العناصر الشرطه المتواجدين بان هذا الوفد
هو للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان مره قبل
دقيقه من الان اذا كانت الصوره قد وضحت
يعني ظهرت لكم قبل دقيقه هنا انا انتقلت
الى بناء اخر على مقربه من البناء الاول
وهذا البناء يتالف من ست طوابق في كل طابق
اربع شقق على ما يبدو ان هذا البناء حكومي
او له يعني حساسيه عند الدوله كما تشاهدون
الان يعني اعداد
العناصر من الشرطه والمخابرات التركيه ومن
كل الفروع الامنيه متواجده بكثره ونحن
اكثر من هذا القدر لا نستطيع ان نقترب من
هذا المكان ما تزال الان عمليات انتشال
الجرحى ويعني القتلى مستمره قبل دقيقه من
الان ايضا قاموا باخراج شخص واخذوه باتجاه
المستشفى كما تشاهدون الان الكاميرا ربما
تكون اوضح من كل الكلام الذي
به اعداد القتلى في هذا البناء تقدر
بالعشرات حقيقه لا يوجد اي احصائيه دقيقه
لم نكن نع
لم بها ربما 200 الى 300 متر عن البناء
الاول هذا البناء في حي احمد وسط ولايه
شارلي اورفا وتحديدا هذا هذا الدوار يعتبر
هو مركز الولايه وهو دوار عابده